Stigler and His Law of Eponymy
Back in 1968, one of the fathers of modern
sociology and National Medal of Science award
winner Robert K. Merton explored the phenomenon
of what he called the “Matthew Effect”
while writing a paper discussing how seniority
or perceived prestige seemed to be the deciding
factor in who would be given credit for a
scientific discovery or breakthrough, regardless
of the actual work put in by those involved.
Merton was inspired to research this idea
while writing a paper about the history and
possible explanations for the common “simultaneous
discovery” phenomenon (two or more scientists
making an identical breakthrough or discovery
at roughly the same time independently of
one another) in 1963.
He noted that in almost every case he found,
the more famous scientist inevitably ended
up being credited with the discovery, regardless
of who was really first and the actual magnitude
of the contribution they made compared to
the other individual.
Merton decided to dub the phenomenon “The
Matthew Effect” after Matthew 25:29, a Bible
verse which reads: “For to every one that
has shall be given, and he shall have abundance:
but from him that has not shall be taken away
even that which he has.”
Just joking, this is actually Steven Stigler,
the other is of Merton...
Stephen Stigler
Merton explored the concept of the Matthew
Effect in a paper aptly titled, The Matthew
Effect in Science which was read by, among
others, statistician, Stephen Stigler who
would eventually end up corresponding with
Merton over their mutual interest in the field
of sociology.
In 1979, Stigler was asked if he’d like
to contribute an essay for a book dedicated
to Merton to celebrate Merton’s upcoming
retirement (such books are known in the world
of academia as a “Festschrift”).
Though he was initially hesitant to contribute
anything as he’d never actually met Merton
in person, only ever corresponding with him
via letters and occasionally on the phone,
Stigler read through some of his old papers
and hatched a rather novel idea.
Knowing that Merton had written extensively
on the concept of misapplied credit in the
scientific world and that, as Merton had previously
coined the term “self-fulfilling prophecy”
in his 1948 paper of the same name, he had
a particular fondness for examples of rules
which proved themselves, Stigler decided to
pen a paper that incorporated both concepts.
The result was Stigler’s Law of Eponymy,
a 10 page essay more or less explicitly copying
Merton’s previous work exploring the history
of misapplied eponymic rewards.
In this paper, Stigler defined “his” law
as: “No scientific discovery is named after
its original discoverer”.
Presumably for anyone who didn’t get the
joke, the paper included a disclaimer in the
abstract, stating:
I have chosen as a title for this paper, and
for the thesis I wish to present and discuss,
“Stigler’s Law of Eponymy.”
At first glance this may appear to be a flagrant
violation of the “Institutional Norm of
Humility,” and since statisticians are even
more aware of the importance of norms than
are members of other disciplines, I hasten
to add a humble disclaimer.
If there is an idea presented here that is
not at least implicit in Merton’s The Sociology
of Science, it is either a happy accident
or a likely error.
Luckily for Stigler, the joke didn’t fall
flat.
Stigler’s Law was not only seen as a genuine,
touching tribute to a man who had made remarkable
contributions to his field, but the “law”
itself fell into general use, being cited
in over a hundred academic papers since Stigler’s
little tribute.
But that’s not the end of the story.
Unbeknownst to Stigler, before his summation
of a portion of Merton’s work in a single
sentence, an almost identical sentiment to
Stigler’s Law had already independently
been expressed by a mathematician called Hubert
Kennedy in 1972, ironically enough around
the same time Merton was exploring the subject
and a year before his The Sociology of Science
was published.
Specifically, Kennedy asserted that: “Mathematical
formulas and theorems are usually not named
after their original discoverers”.
Kennedy dubbed this declaration “Boyer’s
Law” in his paper on the subject, Who Discovered
Boyer’s Law?, published in the January of
1972 edition of The American Mathematical
Monthly.
The “Boyer” he’s referencing here is
mathematical historian Carl Boyer, who had
himself noted a number of instances of this
phenomenon in his 1968 book, A History of
Mathematics.
Specifically, Kennedy stated, in part,
Boyer, in his recent text, A History of Mathematics,
has observed: “Clio, the muse of history,
often is fickle in the matter of attaching
names to theorems!”
… The observation that theorems are not
named after their original discoverers is
amply supported in his book, where some thirty
such cases are explicitly mentioned in Chapters
18 through 24….
Examples here are both the Maclaurin and Taylor
Series, Picard’s Method, and De Morgan’s
rules in logic…
To conclude his little article, Kennedy stated
of his decision to name this proposed law
after Boyer,
It is perhaps interesting to note that this
is probably a rare instance of a law whose
statement confirms its own validity!
To make sure we’re all the same page: Stigler’s
Law, which explicitly posits that the original
creator of an idea never gets credit for it,
a notion previously studied by Merton, was
named after the wrong person (Stigler) on
purpose and credited to someone else (Merton)
so that it was a proof of itself.
And around the same time Merton had been exploring
the idea and about a decade before Stigler’s
Law was so named, a mathematician (Kennedy),
independently put forth more or less the same
law he also purposefully ironically named
after the first scientist he knew about that
had popularly noted this misattribution phenomenon
in academia (Boyer).
So, not once, but twice, Stigler’s Law became
proof of itself, while simultaneously Merton’s
Matthew Effect, which helped inspire it, is
on full display in the ordeal.
Of course, before any of them, famed mathematician
and philosopher Alfred North Whitehead, co-author
of the enormously influential Principia Mathematica,
noted in a lecture he gave to the British
Association for the Advancement of Science
in September of 1916, “Everything of importance
has been said before by somebody who did not
discover it.”